individually we can have defining
moments families can have defining
moments and certainly characters
if they are lifelike
we'll have moments that define them as
well
can you tell us why the movie ordinary
people
was a defining moment in your life
i think when i saw ordinary people
i was about 17 years old and it was the
first
really serious
movie i had seen you know after chitty
chitty bang bang and
[Music]
it also really spoke to who i was as a
kid i was
uh
kind of a socially awkward
lonely kid and so i felt you know
whatever discomfort went with
with that and
ordinary people showed this main
character
who looked on the outside
like he had everything together and
like he didn't
experience the kind of pain
that i experienced
but then the film because it's
a beautifully told story
reveals his secret life and in his
secret life he's actually
just come out of
treatment
after a suicide attempt and he's going
to high school he's singing in the choir
he looks to everyone like
he's
one of the ones who's really got it all
together
and for the first time as i sat in the
audience i realized
oh it's possible
that
what's on the surface isn't what's
really going on
um underneath
that's i guess something adults know i
didn't know that as a 17 year old and
so that film
showed me that i wasn't the only one so
that was that was the first thing that
made a huge difference uh to me and then
the second thing was i realized
oh so the people around me might
actually be in pain even though it's not
obvious i need to treat people
differently
and that is something that has
continued to shape me
you know decades later i look at people
differently because of what that film
taught me about
other human beings and then the third
thing for me
was
i saw for the first time what a movie
could be and so i thought
this is what i want to do i want to tell
these kinds of stories
that reveal
characters and that
move people that provide meaningful
emotion
so for me seeing ordinary people became
a dividing line in my own life on
multiple levels and so for me that is a
defining moment
and i assume you saw it in the theater i
did i saw it in the theater
i owned the dvd it's still wrapped in
cellophane because i can't bear to go
back and watch it i'm afraid it either
is not as good as i remember or
it will be
[Music]
i don't know i i don't want it to
disappoint me and so i just keep it
under wraps
yeah yeah i i can agree with doing
something it's almost like it's frozen
in time there's something special there
that's exactly right yeah and i don't
want to disturb that memory
because that memory
is vivid and
is kind of a bedrock of
the person i've become
and how were other people leaving the
theater after watching that film
i think other people were
powerfully moved by it uh mary tyler
moore delivers uh fantastic performance
as the sort of
cold-hearted
mother who is
uh
the whole time she's on screen you fear
she's driving her son to suicide and i
remember wanting to like take my shoe
off in the theater and show it at this
throw it at the screen when she was on
screen which is you know what a
testament to
to that performance
so i think you know other people were
really moved i'm not sure how many
people
uh would
point back to that experience as a
defining moment in their lives it's one
of the things about film i think that is
fascinating to me that we all have
different responses to it that are
partly shaped by the film itself but
partly shaped by us and
what we bring to the film who are the
characters and ordinary people so you've
got the dad uh played by donald
sutherland uh the mom played by mary
tyler moore and then the 17 year old son
and then there's a there's another
brother who's really absent from the
movie because he
drowned um
before the events of the movie
that was a defining moment for that
family and each one of these
characters responds in a different way
mary tyler moore's mother character
kind of makes it clear to her surviving
son that she wishes
that the other brother had survived
and that becomes
the
seed of
his misery
is that sense of being
rejected
by his mother and his dad is trying to
figure out how to put his family back
together after the tragic loss of the
one son
and the just the terrible chemistry
that's going on between
mother and the surviving son played by
timothy hutton
and
they're all doing the best they can
but it it
it feels so real
at least to me sitting in the theater it
felt like this is a real family i didn't
feel like i was watching a movie and
uh and i think that that's also informed
even
the way that i approach
writing uh
as a screenwriter that's the tone i go
for i love
naturalism
i don't write big bombastic
uh comic book kinds of material because
that's not what speaks to me it is that
sense of i've gotten lost in a dream
and
uh this feels
in some ways more real than reality
because uh a great film
[Music]
reveals more
of the characters
than
sometimes i'm able to discover of the
people that i actually know
and i find i really crave
understanding who's really there and so
a film that shows that to me i really
love and i
i strive to
do that as a storyteller as well to
really peel back the layers and reveal
who the characters are that we're
dealing with
i'm just curious when did you purchase
the dvd to ordinary people
um
i probably bought that something like 10
years ago you know i think i just came
across it
on a shelf somewhere
and
when i first
had that thing in my hands i thought
well i should i should watch this and
that i just kind of felt resistance uh
in myself to that and so then it ended
up on my shelf of dvds and now it's
even hard to find a dvd player in the
house if i wanted to watch it
can you give us a general explanation of
what a defining moment is
kathy
who's my co-author and my wife and i
first encountered the idea of defining
moments
through
a
mentor of ours
a television writer producer named
coleman locke
and he was mentoring us through a
rewrite of a feature film uh that we we
had written early in our careers
called after the
truth and
coleman made us work uh really really
hard he told us we would come to hate
him
and i thought that that was hyperbole
but he was right he pushed us so hard
we didn't come to hate him we have a
tremendous respect for him
but i remember foolishly asking him at
one point do other writers really work
this hard
and
i've come to find out yes they do the
good ones do but he he had this idea
that he shared with us and the idea was
all of us
have a handful of experiences that have
profoundly shaped us
so
we live through lots of moments every
day in our lives but not every moment is
equal in terms of its impact on shaping
us
and coleman believed that there were
about maybe a half dozen
moments that each one of us could point
to
that
account for much of the person that we
are today and his idea was that
the same would be true of characters and
if we wanted to deeply understand our
characters what drives them
how that broken character got broken
or how that broken character eventually
heals
that we would
locate that half dozen or so moments
that have defined those characters
and that that would actually be more
valuable than understanding how much
change is in the character's pocket or
you know so many of the infinite number
of details that we could know about
about a character
uh coleman's thought was
it is these moments that define the
character that
tell you more than anything else you
could possibly know
and
so kathy and i began doing that work
with our characters
looking into their pasts to discover the
moments that it shaped them
and then looking into the time of the
story the time that's actually unfolding
in a movie or television
episode and saying what are the
the moments that happened live
in front of our eyes that
not only
have formed a character but now
in
in real time before us transform
the character into who they're becoming
so
um
for us what we discovered
about defining moments that helps us to
locate them is they always tend to
create this boundary between before and
after
we talk about the time
before the house burned down and the
time after the house burned down
all of us
on this planet will talk about the time
before the pandemic
and
please god the time after the pandemic
at some point
so the planet can have a defining moment
individually we can have defining
moments families can have defining
moments and certainly characters
if they are lifelike
we'll have moments that define them as
well
how many defining moments are there in
ordinary people
boy you know in ordinary people because
it's been so many decades since i saw
the film that i can just say off the top
of my head
there was the moment of the drowning
so when
the oldest brother
dies tragically
that is a moment that defines the whole
family
and then also and so that happens before
the movie begins and then another
defining event is
when timothy hutton's character
attempt suicide
and that creates another
before and after moment
for purposes of the film
the impact of that attempted suicide is
that
we as the audience as soon as we know
about that
are on the edge of our seats because we
fear
that
he's going to
complete the act
that he's going to take his life and
we like this kid
and we view that
that would be tragic and so we are
rooting for that not to happen
we are
infuriated by his mother's coldness to
him
every time he tries to connect with her
she
pushes him away
and
we just want to scream at her don't you
see
what's happening don't you see how much
he needs you can't you
put your arms around your son
all of that
is rooted in that defining moment of the
suicide attempt which is
made known to the audience so that we
we get the good out of it we get the
emotional juice that flows from that
and
then
there's a defining moment
of
a kind of connection if i am remembering
the movie correctly that happens between
timothy timothy hutton and his dad
donald sutherland
that
makes you believe that maybe they're
going to make it
and so it creates this other turning
point a kind of a kind of
provisional healing
there may be more in there those are the
three that
that remain in my memory
so it's a film
of a lot of pain and
grief
but it's also a hopeful film
but it's bittersweet because
the mom's character doesn't
get to participate in that
reconciliation and again if i go back
and never crack open that dvd i may find
out i'm remembering wrong but in my
memory those are the three key defining
moments that
immediately come to my mind